hey hannibal we're watching stand up on
youtube
it wasn't funny man media
a little while back i did this tv show
with two chains called most expensive as
[ __ ]
it was cool for me because i got to ask
him a very important question
do you feel pressured to wear multiple
chains all the time do
you feel pressure to wear multiple
chains all the time
i feel like that's a i feel like that's
a solid question
here's how he answered the question shut
your high ass
which to me sounds like a deflection
and a yes don't try to pin this on me
being hot
yes i'm high but i thought of this [ __ ]
four years ago
sober we finally crossed paths got to
get it off my chest today
two chains is fascinating because he's
very religious
and also materialistic so sometimes he
uses his music to ask god for luxurious
[ __ ] like this
i don't give a [ __ ] last night i pray
that god will make a bentley truck dear
god
dear god it's me two chains hey
quick question you ever thought about
making a bentley suv
bentley truck guy i'm tired of this
sedan come on man
family's growing need that leg room that
cargo space think about it
bentley suv chop chop amen get on that
[ __ ] amen
change
yeah he prays on his songs all the time
sometimes he asks for custom [ __ ] like
this
last night i prayed to guard and asked
for him to make a drop truck
dear god it's me again
two tanks from
the bentley suv prayer that you didn't
answer
[ __ ] [ __ ] anyways
you ever thought about making a drop top
suv
convertible suv god and i know what
you're about to say
but i already asked exhibit he says he
doesn't do that anymore
so humbly lord i come to you
second after exhibit of course you know
there's an order of operations with [ __ ]
think about it though drop top suv sun
in my face
wind in my dreads two tanks
amen chop chop and don't come with no
jeep wrangler [ __ ] that don't count to
me
peace
[Applause]
he won't stop he is a man obsessed
[Applause]
god this is my final request
uh just
they just set a google alert for bentley
truck
[Music]
is